par rapport au nombre d'habitants
aujourd'hui la population a augmenté
quasiment doublé et s'est bien stabilisé
mais il faut un certain nombre d fois su
qu aujourd'hui il a fallu pendant ses
trente ans préparé cela donc mettre les
trois il est en condition de pouvoir
réaliser des factures encore beaucoup
plus importante par rapport à ce que
nous avons réalisé au coût de 6 30 ans
comme l'assainissement le stade l'église
se font de mer et aujourd'hui nous
relançons sur nouvelle école nous
lançons sur audi sport nous relançons
sur tout ce qui concerne la même zone de
mouillage organisée
tout cela c'est dans le cadre du vivre
ensemble de l'aménagement du territoire
du développement économique et social
nous avançons pas à pas mais il faut
surtout garder le pas que nous avons
gagné depuis ces trente ans